[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation it is John
and koi genre here at the beautiful IMAX
HQ in Playa Vista California and we just
got done seeing Transformers rise of the
beast but before we talk about that just
want to say a huge thank you to the folks
at IMAX for having us out if you follow this
Channel at all you know that IMAX is pretty
much our favorite way to see most any movie in
a movie like this at the scale it exists on is
absolutely the peak experience so if you got
an IMAX near you go see Transformers rise of
the beasts at an IMAX theater if it's in IMAX I
see it and I'm actually the point where I have
to schedule my tickets ahead of time to catch it
that's sweet sweet IMAX week so see it in IMAX
absolutely sir and also before we hop into the
review leave a like leave a like for Greg Greg
is busy at home slaving away on an emergency
edit otherwise he would have been here and I
mean he missed a lot because they actually not
only did we see the movie Peter Cullen showed
up did a q a it was a lovely and then stayed
after to hang out absolutely absolutely he
did but anyway Transformers rise of the beasts
seventh live-action Transformers Motion Picture
how does it shape up well let's talk about
that neither of us is a huge expert on the
vast lore that these stories come with that these
characters come with we got a lot to talk about
and before we do just gonna give a brief synopsis
of the film I'm so prepared hey how's it going
just keeping everything on track right now
I love carrots Optimus Prime and the Autobots
take on their biggest challenge yet when a new
threat capable of destroying the entire planet
emerges they must team up with a powerful faction
of Transformers known as the maximals to save
Earth beautiful nice Cameo Your Best Peter Cullen
voice yeah that's actually a pretty sure way to
describe the movie A lot of it takes place in the
1990s taking place after the events of Bumblebee
Loosely acknowledging that as you know part of
its immediate Canon and I know what you're all
first and foremost Champion to hear about the
Transformers across this movie are gorgeous
to look at as always and there are a whole
bunch of different kinds because not only do you
have the Autobots but you also have the maximals
coming into play and the terror cons the Agents
of the god-being Unicron who is essentially like
the Galactus of this universe yeah I love that
parallel during the group there was a lot of like
space Cosmic comic stuff and I was like oh they're
going there absolutely and things that do sort
of remind you of certain other especially like DC
kind of movies visually and aesthetically and even
voice absolutely yeah and and obviously Optimus
Prime is you know the sort of central Transformer
but I think the the character who really stole
the show this time around was Pete Davidson as
Mirage you know dressed in this beautiful Porsche
packaging I'm a Porsche guy so I got a kick out of
that but what did you think of a mirage made me so
happy I was thinking the entire time I don't want
to realize who this is because I'm having so much
joy not knowing and then when it was Pete Davidson
I was like of course it was absolutely I really
think he nailed the I have to be somehow the new
Bumblebee without being bumblebee but also in a
movie with Bumblebee and a movie that will also be
Optimus Prime Centric like that's a lot of things
to joke you have to be inherently Charming in
small doses you have to be charismatic in a really
unique way you have to be something that's new to
the franchise but also familiar it's a really tall
order and I think delivered I really think the
bond between our humans and especially Mirage was
uniquely strong in this particular installment of
the Transformers yeah absolutely and it certainly
brings that sort of endearing quality that your
human main character bonding with him so he's
kind of filling the Bumblebee role even though
bumblebee does appear in this movie certainly
Mirage is like your your most chummy Autobot
on the team and then obviously you've got Peter
Cohen reprising the role of Optimus Prime and
and this is still very much sort of his fight
it's an ensemble it's an ensemble piece of these
Transformers but a lot of it does still center
around his journey and his growth as a character
we it's a bit of an edgier take on Optimus Prime
because he is burdened with a lot of remorse and
just the weight of his decisions in the parts of
this war that have you know affected everything up
until now and it's before he's had a lot of time
to spend with Humanity he hasn't had the humanity
he hasn't been endeared to us which I really
like that take so the Rough Around the Edges
had purpose it wasn't just like edgy prime it
was like this is a guy who doesn't yet know what
he's dealing with on this planet in a personal
level which I enjoyed yeah yeah yeah and I mean
neither of us is like a great Transformers expert
necessarily but there are times when you can tell
Maybe maybe certain lines of dialogue in certain
installments maybe don't ring true and here I
thought the the times where they did flirt with
the line of you know what his character's supposed
to be what the essence is supposed to be it did
serve that sort of challenge to his principles and
and his growth as a character so I thought yeah
it was mostly appropriately done and then we have
the character of Optimus primal as well the sort
of head maximal these descendants of the Autobots
that have been all through time and space and are
now you know joining the fight here in the present
moment there's a lot of timey ones in the store
show Absolutely from Beast Wars which Beast Wars
is probably my best Touchstone for Transformers
but I can tell you got uh so I mean and a lot of
people are looking forward to the maximals first
and foremost from this movie how did you feel
about them I was so enamored by the physicality I
was so enamored by the fact that it's hard enough
to make a Transformer look like it's tangible in
our world it's even harder to make a Transformer
look like it has authentic animal physicality
but also is a machine that also has authentic
textures it's a lot of brilliant Computing like
the first Transformers I really think as much as
people don't look back on it as fondly uh because
of like the six movies we've gotten through it
doesn't feel as novel anyway like there's not
a novelty to Transformers that first one was
mind-blowing seeing those special effects seeing
those pyrotechnics seeing the baehem that was a
mind-blowing experience this was that for these
creatures this was just as mind-blowing me there's
a scene and it's not a spoiler at all but there's
a scene where you see Beast Wars side by side with
humans side by side with cars and if you'd just
taken out the cars it would look like a cartoon
that looked photo real but if you just take out
the Beast it looks like a car ad like it's all of
your brain going like I've seen this before but
I haven't seen it but I have seen it and it was
this really beautiful suspension of disbelief
blending all these worlds and I really bought
it in a really fun way yeah absolutely I did too
and you know they aren't the most heavily featured
characters in terms of dialogue and skin screen
time but their impression is definitely felt and
they definitely do take advantage of that sort
of mix between you know the more organic animal
shapes and then you know the train Transformers
car mechanics they bring a nice new flavor to it
as do the the terracons who are sort of your main
villains LED mainly by Scourge who I didn't even
realize yeah who's he's kind of the Steppenwolf of
this movie and I really think it worked I really
think this landed with not only Menace but you're
intrigued by him as the character evolves you want
to know more I think that the franchise overall
this is the seventh one of these I think the first
one is the bar that said I think the first one is
unique and I think it really is what people wanted
a Transformers movies live action and then I think
they've kind of strayed from that path like they
took certain notes and went really aggressively
one way or the other I feel like they've had to
Chip Away back down to something contained and I
feel like this in bumblebee are the most authentic
two Transformers we've had yeah because I mean
this has all the action and the Carnage and the
cool stuff that you want but it also comes with I
think the right sort of cheese yeah like whenever
it dipped into cheese or haminess it was always
in a way that put a big smile on my face and that
brought me back to the spirit of you know just
playing with action figures and being a kid in
the 90s and there are certain only tons of 90s
just pop culture Spanish characters soundtrack
my favorite character in this movie is the 90s
soundtrack absolutely the soundtrack is so good
it's a great throwback and it definitely puts
you in the time and place and yeah I mean music
is absolutely transportive that way but I thought
what they chose was nicely handled and I thought
this movie did a nice job of acknowledging that
debating that and you know even though it is kind
of silly having humans involved still justifying
it with enough I don't know just reason to suit
the kind of movie that it is and it led to some
really fun moments with the human cast which is
led by uh Anthony Ramos and Dominique Fishback who
are both great like this is a movie that doesn't
heavily capitalize on like the dramatic side
of the human stuff but it does give you enough
to care about with them they are very charismatic
and and they take the roles just seriously enough
this isn't my favorite franchise this is my
favorite movie this summer but what I want
out of a Transformers movie this was so if you
love Transformers you're going to love this if
you don't love trying Transformers you might not
love this but it is what it promises and I think
there's an inherent 80s Nostalgia 90s Nostalgia
joy that is very unique to this franchise and this
is playing The Equalizer of that very beautifully
yeah absolutely and I mean people were going off
about like what's the shortest Transformers movie
yet and I mean it's not that short of a movie yeah
but it does clip along in a way that does not over
bear on you too much and that does maintain that
level of fun and yeah that throwback quality that
makes you feel like you're a kid and I mean the
action certainly you're coming to Transformers
for an action movie for beautiful visuals and
crazy Contraptions and whatnot it's not like
the most everything is a money shot Michael
based style but there are certainly beautiful
sequences that take advantage of the Sci-Fi and
then there are sequences that ground you nicely in
you know the bits of the human Stakes we do check
in with there are a lot of really good supporting
characters and the voice cast you know I didn't
necessarily always you know it's like Ron Perlman
is Optimus primal he does a fantastic job for the
time he is there I maybe wanted a little bit more
of that Michelle yo is air razor who's probably
the most heavily featured of the maximals even
more I mean in terms of screen time than Optimus
primal but she does a fine job in her role Peter
Dinklage is Scourge which I had no idea about and
there are a couple other really fun voices mixed
into the cast uh for the I mean your main Autobot
team is Optimus Bumblebee Mirage and RC but you
do get a few other Autobots as well as maximals
and terracons in the mix chitars in here the whole
thing kind of culminates in a really fun adventure
that has again all the Transformers lore stuff
that you want and it's more focused on that while
giving enough create it's kind of like a Godzilla
movie it gives enough Credence to his human
characters that you can endear to them I agree
and I think the pacing was one of its strengths
I think it's going to be good for kids that are
discovering the franchise as well as people that
have loved it for 40 years honestly this was uh
kind of a greatest hits recall I really think this
is launching a franchise in a really beautiful
way I think it allows for us to go forward while
acknowledging the past which I want our equals to
do but it does feel like a new world in a really
beautiful way and I'm very optimistic about the
future of the Transformers because of this movie
yeah and there are a couple big surprises toward
the end that we cannot talk about whatsoever at
the internet but you should avoid the internet and
they're absolutely so I'm very excited to see what
the response is because it's something that I
had no idea to even think about yeah but yeah
ultimately just overall feelings what would you
say I'd say number one or two of the franchise I
think uh I think right up there with the first one
on bumblebee like I think uh you know Transformers
one uh bumblebee in this are all at another
level and I think I was really impressed with
Anthony Ramos and I was really impressed with the
directing I was really impressed with the world
built and I love the almost guy and and his dog
story that is the Transformers I feel like there's
always this like companionship that translate
between Transformers then their human element that
they really captured well here so it's able to
manage uh like a really good equalizer of all my
favorite elements of Transformers in a very unique
recoil that feels like it's launching a franchise
while giving some love to the past and I I think
that's a really good place for the Transformers
to be right now yeah yeah it clipped right along
it has my favorite car uh the skyline is in here
there's a Nissan Skyline r34j ADM Edition which is
the car that Brian drives in Fast and the Furious
and the color scheme of the Porsche is the same
color scheme as brian's skyline so I had a lot
of Fast and Furious Love happening also RC is
Ducati was my favorite motorcycles they have
good taste in vehicles there's a lot of beautiful
Machinery on display from Cars to bikes to planes
to otherwise and yeah it's the kind of movie where
it works more than it doesn't and even when it is
teetering on Being Cheesy or hammy or whatever
it is again in a way that put a big smile on my
face and that I enjoyed from front to back which
is kind of all you can ask for from one of these
movies did not outstay its welcome definitely gave
me those Thrills great use of setting too between
the New York scenes there's some stuff that takes
place in Peru and other parts of the world and uh
and yeah it got me optimistic I would come back
and watch more of this version of Transformers so
I am Optimus Mystic myself Adam Optimist Prime
optimistic it used to be that was my nickname
a lot of time not anymore Madam Terror John this
is the first time we've done one of these on the
street this is fun I know it'll get more refined
more opportunities we get I'm just proud of us
doing my best here but uh but yeah guys leave us
your thoughts have you seen Transformers rise of
the beasts did you go on IMAX what did you think
and uh yeah we'll catch you on the next one don't
forget to leave a like thank you again to IMAX
be well people reject Nation roll out [Music]